[Music]
it is time for everybody's favorite
segment
facts are your friends
now listen
i stumbled on this article back in 2019
and it came back up again recently and
it's by the great peter atiyah peter at
tiamd.com we'll link to it in the show
notes and
he sends out a weekly newsletter
after
sign up for his newsletter before mine
but get on his he's just wise um but
he wrote about conspiracy theories and
he wrote an article on conspiracy theory
theories
and if you've been in america the last i
don't know a couple of years there's
been a wide range of conspiracy theories
everywhere so
here's a couple of things he notes
um as why he thinks there's so many
conspiracy theories that have emerged
number one
truth is hard to accept
the idea that a sad and lonely sick man
could climb up in the library window
and shoot a sitting president with all
of the might of the u.s government
around
and alter geopolitics that if that our
our
country is that fragile
or that 19 guys just gotten a couple of
airplanes and crashed him and that's all
it took
to rattle this country to its core
he writes it's better to have a
compelling and elaborate story we tend
to believe that extraordinary events
deserve extraordinary story so we're not
okay with things being that simple
the second thing is there's a history of
genuine conspiracies right
they've been real like watergate et
cetera and here's what he has an
evolutionary purpose he says we're
hardwired for survival purposes
a splash in the water or movement in the
brush could be a rock in the wind but
better to assume a saber-toothed cat and
a venomous snake it's far more likely to
be nothing but on the off chance we're
wrong we need vigilance to stay alive
and there's been some conspiracy
theories a few
the third one we're significant junkies
we just want to make sense out of a
confusing world and we're willing to go
along with just those stories if it
helps our brains attach meaning to them
now
i am somebody who is a big fan of
i don't know
data rational thinking logic things like
that that's just like a fun thing for me
we all have that one friend though
that would prefer
to listen to the man with 17 youtube
followers out of the trunk of his car
with a mobile phone microphone going
talking into like a fisher-price radio
set
guess what everybody i figured it out
listen to this we all have that friend
my friend
happens to be
rachel cruz check this out
are you not believing any conspiracy
theories i understand not all of them
not most of them but you don't believe
in any conspiracy there
you just think the government's just
batting a thousand and telling us the
whole truth
that's a strong stance to take
and so
we're back and so in studio i've got my
good friend rachel
cruz do this
john it's the concrete cinema gosh okay
so we don't account for actual humans
being greedy and evil in the midst of
all of this here we go it's just like
during my talking about dr t
theories i could feel it on you
peter schmeter i don't know who this man
is i don't know who this man i'm just
kidding he's the smartest middle class
all right so let's rattle through some
of these okay okay and i'm not okay let
me say this i love conspiracy theories
okay yes i'm not like i haven't written
books like i'm not all like what's in my
head i will translate to you and i will
tell you but i think but if it comes out
of your head but if you get if you get
like you can't like pop quiz me on like
very very specifics of each one because
i'm like i'm not okay these are all
let's go let's get breakfast
yeah and the reason she doesn't write
them down because then they'll know
that's why
it just keeps it all in my steps on my
phone because i'm like certain countries
own certain things she just wanna if she
writes them down they get outside the
tin foil
everywhere all right
number one okay
jfk
oh yeah total inside job total inside
job for sure
have you have you been to the have you
been to the textbook
and if you stood in that window you're a
gun guy john like you you appreciate it
i've never stood in the window you did
well that's part of the tour you go and
you you go in by the window where he
shot
you have to be
a phenomenal
sniper
to be able to do that three shots in
seven seconds
and a gun that probably is can't look
you can't it just like mechanically
would be very difficult for that to
happen
and to actually aim
at a target like that
i mean i it looks nearly impossible that
and then
you're so happy right now cia
the mob yes for sure lyndon b johnson
lyndon b johnson we're on to you come
i don't know grassy knoll so i do
believe there are multiple shooters i do
think
lee harvey wallswald obviously had
involvement
okay but i just think stuff was
happening i just think there was stuff
happening vietnam i mean there was a lot
the cia wanted to go
and assassinate fidel castro okay that's
actually documented okay okay there are
actual documents on that it's clear
there's probably like four different
reasons
why people would want him dead okay
versus some crazy guys like i'm the best
shooter in history and i have a magical
gun that can reload even though that
doesn't exist in the 60s and shoot three
times no the grassy knoll there was a
nut yes other yes other things were
happening moon landing oh we're just
like go for everything we're going down
oh wow a moon landing uh i'm going to
judge me
if it if
it didn't happen i wouldn't be shocked
oh why yeah
uh height of the cold war the soviet
union when you look at all of the facts
going against it's like we had to beat
it uh 30 billion dollars was put into
nasa that year 30 billion to do that so
if they didn't land on the moon there
would be like this uprising like this
idea of like nasa what do you do like or
they funnel money into the secret alien
operations questioning question
questioning and you look and they had
the tech they did have the film
technology to pull it off yes and what
1963 right no no that was that was that
was jfk i remember the exact date yeah
yeah
69 thank you what about the pictures
like do you think they've there's actual
probes on mars right now
uh uh no i'm not talking about current
okay you think we think we're there now
yeah yeah
and then you look at the pictures though
and it is odd there's no stars like
there are a couple things like they just
missed details
so that's my thought like with that one
i think okay they got a group of
hollywood producers in there to do this
like well guys we gotta nail this we
have to trick earth we have to trick the
planet
and of the people in the room they were
like
son of a forgot the stars like really
there's a guy or it's like i just hate
the politics of the day no we have to do
a flag we had to beat the soviet union i
mean there were things and and kennedy i
mean he went on a whole thing right
about
yeah all of it and i just think that
america he rallied around something we
could do together
he he's like punch people i think
like in real life because
yeah oh yeah
so i don't want to be punched hey listen
listen it could have happened
actually we did not land on the moon in
1969 i'd be like i mean i'm just not
shocked all right denver airport oh yeah
temperature airport okay now we're
starting to get real crazy
so you and i have talked just hanging
out like hey john you know there's like
a thing under the denver yeah denver
airport okay what's underneath the
denver airport for our listeners who
have no idea okay well the denver
airport so denver had a full functioning
airport very close to the city and it
was fine sure maybe a little small but
it was fine so when you fly to denver
you know you drive like 45 minutes to
get to downtown denver i mean it is out
there right okay
um and if you haven't been to denver
there's these um they're small but
they're around the city
they're called the rocky mountains which
make making big things hard
that's nothing in case of good
continuously
oh no that is not like no no no no no no
no no we're not talking geography here
we are we are this is we're focused on
facts dang there are others so yeah so
no the denver airport one this one is
kind of i get it it sounds silly but
again i'm like i mean who knows okay so
what is it so it's the idea that the new
world order which there's actually a
plaque outside of the denver statue and
literally at the bottom of the statue in
the circle it says dedicated to the new
world order like it really
literally says that so i'm like i don't
understand why people are like oh i know
so the new world order it's not like the
illuminati sort of but it's the idea the
idea that there are a group of people
across the world powerful people that
control everything right like we think
our elections
no it's all it's all controlled by by
this group of people okay so
this is this is the theory i'm not
saying i believe it 100
this is the theory though and so in
order to
control the world and we can bring in
biblical revelation too
okay that a mass genocide has to happen
eventually to
allow the world order to control the
population because they can't control
every person right now on the planet
clearly there's too many absolutely uh
the antichrist i don't know like you can
you can start to like weave in some
biblical stuff here
but so the idea is that there has to be
a master in the side so you go around
the denver airport today okay
and the paintings have you seen the
paintings on the wall are the creepiest
bizarre some artists and they they blame
they're like it's art i'm like no it's
not there are literal paintings google
it of a man and a huge man on a gas mask
and coffins below him with with children
of different nations like different like
at the american flag with different yes
there's that photo there i mean the most
weird bizarre dark paintings are all
over the denver airport so it's hints of
painting
of the massachusetts because here's the
conclusion at the bottom of the denver
airport there were all these tunnels
when the construction was happening
there's footage aerial footage of these
massive tunnels underneath the airport
so the theory is is that is where
the new world order is going to go
stay in these bunkers
when the mass genocide happens so that
they can't survive
literally on this show
i take calls all over people all over
the world
um explain to me what's going on in
their life
and one time i think on the show maybe
twice i have said the words i don't
really know what to say next
and this is number three i don't have
so we were at family dinner no this was
like this was this one's been around for
like 10 years yeah and we're at ramsey
family dinner and i'm telling my family
this because i'm like this is insane
y'all the denver airport is sketchy like
when you you know and i'm telling them i
just told you
and dad dave was like that is the
stupidest thing i think i've ever heard
and i was like oh you're interested
you're part of it
dave ramsey might be part of the new
world order i was like save me a bunker
save me listen one of one of the most
important things about new world orders
is they they wink at the world through
their art and statues
and i didn't have any i had no idea i
would have thought why is that why is it
that why is that why is the airport
though dedicated to the new world order
what it like
why would they why would they put that
there i'm just curious i thought the new
world order was like a wwe group like a
worldwide wrestling group
right
aren't they wrestlers are they wrestlers
why would they dedicate an airport real
quick on these flat earth
uh i researched it i don't believe it
i love that you you like i got a
specialist there are a few documentaries
i watched so i was like what if what if
but i do you think the world could have
been out serving the poor and you're
like nope i have another use for that
valuable hour of my life
i got to find out if this earth thing is
real um do you believe in any john do
you think anything is true hold on do
you think anything in history has
happened anything
that is not the truth of what was being
told oh absolutely yes okay so it opens
your mind to the idea that there are
people that do things and they tell the
public one thing and we're all like okay
sure yes that's what's happening yes
when actually
other stuff was really happening i
absolutely do okay and i like them for
fun
yes but i really identify with what he
said about
um
that the
the idea that
one guy could climb up in there and take
out the president
and alter world history
yes
i don't want to live in that world
and so it feels better it feels better
to say no no there was a huge plot that
everybody was in on it and they all knew
what was happening and then they've
pacified the rest of us because we
couldn't handle it
i have been in boardrooms when we've had
hard conversations and nobody lied
walking out but everyone said this
conversation stays here it has to
because what's going on out there
they can't handle a friend of mine was
uh she was a
an attorney for a finance attorney and
when they were trying to make the fed
minutes public record
and she was like
god help us they have to be able to have
conversations in there that the general
public cannot stomach we don't need that
made that and i i believe that there are
certain conversations that shouldn't be
everywhere totally right yes yes so yes
i like the idea that okay the cia all
got together was like we have to do this
it happened now let's move on
i like that version of the world better
than
no that guy could just go like the whole
thing that we are dancing on is that
flimsy right can you alter that totally
absolutely absolutely um and so i like
that but yes and but for me i'm like
it's a hard balance of
withholding information yes for
security you know and i get that like i
can be rational i understand but also
when you're just lied to when you're
just lied to though there's a part of me
that the justice in that i hate and i do
think there are things that have
happened in our history correct that i'm
like it's just if it's why and and lied
to for the benefit of other people that
if there are powerful people greedy
people and they want what they want
right and in order to get that it's like
well we'll just do this this and this so
i can get more money or more power and
that's where i think some of this can
stem from
last one yes don't go where are you
gonna go thumbs down because there's
some i don't i don't i won't okay thumbs
up for thumbs down okay microchips oh
yeah oh yeah no those will those are ha
those are actually literally happening
as we speak though for payment yeah
people yeah yeah the people just
reported
you can get a microchip now it's
different than pulling it out of your
pocket and waving it over
than just waving it over
uh because it's part of it's it's
you can't you can i can throw that over
there when it's implanted in you john it
is part of you like they literally
when's the last time you've left it over
like that
left my phone
like what do you mean
what do you mean just walked away from
it for
24 hours
uh
um 2011. 24 hours how yeah how many
hours are we talking
see
ah stop marking the beast
uh so that's my friend listen are some
conspiracy theory theories real yes but
of course they are but listen
most of the time they're not
most of the time there's a group of
people trying to the best they can i
think with the data that they have
and most of the time i have to look in
the mirror and go
do i really really think that they are
implanting chips in
something and i'm just going to put it
in a soda i'm going to drink it and all
of a sudden like they got me is that
really how it's going to happen oh yeah
i don't know
probably not but the thing is do you
believe that there's evil in the world
though of course so i'm like if these if
evil people
have enough power and enough sway
then then it shouldn't be shocking when
evil stuff starts happening right and
then they hide it from us all you know
where they hide it in the denver airport
ladies and gentlemen if you get one
thing out of the segment at all
listen they didn't land on the moon
contrary to what lloyd christmas says in
dumb and dumber and two
never fly to denver